hey everyone welcome back to dc thursday
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council
and the data community fund
and i'm your guide through the vast
sprawling expanse of the modern data
ecosystem
so today we have a amazing guest with
a ton of experience chi chu is here
and she is the chief product officer at
m particle
and today we're going to discuss various
aspects of
cd's customer data platforms
and um she has some interesting thoughts
on differentiating uh
that space and and mental models that he
uses um to frame the space so we'll chat
about that
and we'll also discuss m particle's
unique value proposition
and dig into some of its differentiation
um amongst his other competitors
as well as we'll chat about types of
analytics that companies can consider
once their customer data is actually in
order
so
she is the chief product officer in
particle as i mentioned
previously he was the chief product
officer at twilio
before that he was a vp of consumer
engagement at amazon
before that he was a vp of engineering
at google and before that he was a gm at
microsoft for many years
so she
that's an amazing amount of experience
and we i want to welcome you to the show
thanks for having me here it's great to
be here good to talk to you
so um
with so much experience in the space and
you know decades
under your belt in the tech world
um i'm sure that you've seen lots of
amazing things um happen through the
course of your career
what's what's your best story from
spending the last 20 years
at top tech companies
my best story
uh i had a ton of fun and i've been
really lucky to to work on lots of great
projects i think some of my best ways
are just kind of the fun things that
happen out and around work
um at microsoft remember that there's a
big launch that we had it was a long
hard slog
and on the launch
we had a four-hour food fight
it was nuts it was crazy um and that was
uh very very early in my career when i
was a developer
and then later on you know
there's a funny one where
i was sitting uh waiting for a meeting
uh with uh larry page
sergey brin walks by and he said oh hey
chi i had this idea this is really early
when we work on hangouts it's like i
have this idea
if we were to drop
a few
skydiving bikers out of a blimp over
moscone and landed them on the roof of
moscone
could you get them to have a hangout all
the way
down through the launch um and
uh
it's like uh maybe like
that's a month away like the conference
is a month away google i o is a month
away it's like yeah can you do it and
it's like
we'll try and then
and a month later we dropped a bunch of
uh skydiving bikers out of a blimp and
they had hang on
it was fun it was a lot of fun and you
maintained connectivity all the way down
we maintain connectivity we had uh
network form beaming uh uh dishes that
we pointed at the skydivers but folks on
the ground actually pointed network up
to them and tracked them all the way
down so we have um it was a network
bonded so you have multiple networks
combining the one to beam out
that's great well if you were if you
hadn't already been in a role at google
i would have thought that was a google
interview question
[Laughter]
that's uh that's something um yeah
thanks for sharing that that is quite
the story
and and so what about data um
obviously you know any engineer is
familiar with data and we all use data
databases every day
but but regardless was there sort of a
tipping point in your career when
you started to realize the full power of
data and data analytics
yeah um
actually when i joined amazon they
brought me in to really uh work on a
bunch of the shopping retail experiences
um like what is it like to shop there
end-to-end including especially all the
marketing stuff that happens and the
personalization
all the ads you see and so how do you
make that a great experience um how do
you personalize it and
and this is this is like seven years ago
and
the
the secret sauce
that we ended up really really focusing
on was just personalization
personalization personalization
and that was around how to get
as much of the data as possible from all
around the company
and
activate it um
at amazon we had our own cdp and we've
had an internal cdp and a lot of systems
around that cdp to personalize
every aspect that we could um and uh i
just really learned the power of it
we brought the spend down
by over half
but we increased our effectiveness and
that meant for our customers they got
better service they got
more relevant messages fewer messages
but each one was more relevant and we
increased the the results for the
business
so um so that's where i really uh came
to understand the power of
of data the cdp personalization and what
did you call the the project inside
amazon at the time because this is
probably before
cdp was really a term
it was and there were multiple
components of it uh so like the
the team overall
was the traffic team but there were a
couple of really core systems and one of
the um most fundamental ones one we
called bullseye uh and that like if you
think about like how do you target
really effectively and i think bullseye
was really at the heart of it but there
were other systems sitting around it
like cafe and nest cafe and others that
like the code names of it that really
then utilize bullseye to then send the
most relevant email marketing or on-site
personalization or ads things like that
got it
and and so what was the overall state of
amazon's data infrastructure
at the time um were you using
machine learning models or um you know
other more sophisticated things on top
of this data or how i'm just curious as
to kind of what the what the range of
infrastructure data infrastructure looks
like that they're at that point
um
it definitely matured throughout my time
there and like one of the things i could
give credit for to the company is uh
there was this big
commitment all around the company
around machine learning and growing
advancing capabilities
early on
like at the very beginning
there was a lot of discovery
to figure out what it looked like to
have great machine learning and then
over my time there we went from machine
learning uh starting of deep learning
infrastructure and then really having
the the facilities for
great deep learning as well so
it matured over time but what i would
say is that uh amazon went at it with
sort of all forces where there was
heuristic
to machine learning to deep learning to
model building infrastructure um i i
think
what i learned from there was lean in
really hard like
yeah got it
and when did you when would you say you
start to saw this whole
the term sort of around customer data
platform
emerge was that something that you were
aware of during your time at amazon or
did that come after
um you know you heard about a little bit
um here and there but i don't think it
really
um
it really made sense the world in a
broad sense uh during my time at amazon
i think it started coming near the end
um and we
uh we we talked about like should these
systems be uh brought over to aws
um
but it was so powerful that you know the
conclusion i came to at the time was um
it was
such a secret sauce for retail well
that the time wasn't right to
make that available to the rest of the
world
since then uh certain aspects of it has
have gone over to aws um it always
personalized uh
the leader there was part of part of my
team uh doing uh some of these services
for retail um but
it wasn't really as big um early on and
it's really gained a lot of momentum
yeah and probably i mean credit where
credit's due right probably it was
segment that
um was sort of one of the early you know
companies in the space that sort of made
many of those of us on the outside and
who weren't rolling our own you know
cdp's inside
retail or e-commerce aware of of the
space
but actually i think that's an
interesting segue to your next position
because you ended up going to twilio
um next as chief product officer um tell
me about the circumstances of that move
and and how you ended up taking that job
oh yeah like you know i had a wonderful
time at twilio um a great company uh
went over there for a couple of reasons
uh first of all i i've been in
communications um for since 1999. i feel
that communication is improving our
communications of the world is really
important not only for business but just
for the health of the world um
and uh and toy of course is in the
center of communications
i also i got a chance to get to know
jeff lawson the ceo founder
and the executive team and a wonderful
team uh jeff's an amazing person uh
was excited to work with him um and then
also you know i've worked only these big
huge
companies like amazon and microsoft and
google um and uh
the idea of joining twilio when there
were a thousand people a thousand like
teeny tiny to me uh i was excited on a
new adventure and learning what it's
like to work in a small company um i
really appreciate my time there
yeah amazing
that's great
um
and so what was twilio's view on data
and data infrastructure at the time um
obviously they ended up acquiring
segment
um which i believe you
you had some involvement in um tell us a
little bit about that
you know when we started
twilio's uh investments in data ml uh
were a bit nascent um autopilot was the
primary uh
when i started when you talked about
like the ml team it was synonymous with
autopilot um but over my time there
there was
a lot more investments in
ml
going from the speech recognition um the
the super network that really routes and
re-routes traffic
that became machine learned and really
advanced um i think it's the best breed
in the industry um i think that there's
uh this was a growing investment in it
um
that all led also to
uh looking at things like segment um
that was centered really around the
notion of
twilio has always believed in being
about
enriching uh communications with
customers and enriching that
relationship and if you're going to
enrich the relationship with customers
you really have to understand the
customer
and
a cdp
helps you really understand customers
you've got to look at what they're doing
how they're reacting to you
you can't you can't just be a one-way
blast out to them you've got to have
that full uh feedback loop cycle um and
that data is messy like that the
customers you may speak them on one
channel and they may respond to another
and you've got to collect that
information from all around the company
make sense of it reconcile it in today's
modern world you have to get permissions
you have to be safe and respectful with
consumer data
and then you've got to activate it
and that was the genesis for
um uh
the the value of the cdp
got it and obviously um you know segment
lives on as a as a product um
but but i guess what you're saying is
that there's probably sort of a two-fold
um angle for the acquisition one is that
tulia wanted to enrich their own
communication with their own customers
sort of on the twilio
services side um but but separately um
obviously they they sort of kept up with
the segment customers separately so it
seems like there's kind of a duality of
uh of of what the outcome um entailed is
that would you say that's fair
yeah i i would say overall if um
for a company like tulia and many others
who really care about helping people
uh grow
the relationship with their consumers um
like understanding utilizing the data
is critically important and
is a really important element of that
mm-hmm
yeah great makes sense
um so
so based on all this experience
um you ended up
uh joining in particle and you know tell
us about like what's special about
imparticle and why you decided to join
the company yeah and and particle has
been a really fun ride so far and
looking forward to all that we can do in
the future um uh for me
like as i said one of the motivations
for me going to tulio was um a personal
one of wanting to
work in a small company um
i left twilio
it grew from 1 000 to 6 500 that was
incredible
and i joined and particle when we were
sub 200 so it's a new a new notion of
small
but i love the focus on
uh customer data um uh what everything i
learned from amazon about the importance
of it the power of it um i i really
believe in and
i'm excited uh to work in a company like
imparticle that's just laser focused on
activating customers data um and i love
the executive team here um and uh you
know we'll we'll be excited to see
uh how we can shape the world
great
so share with us your your mental model
around the space because i know you have
some
um interesting thoughts in the way that
you sort of describe the overall cdp
landscape
yeah and you know
cp i see a lot of times cdp's is like on
old days when you would say like a crm
you ask like 20 people what a crm is you
get 20 different answers um and
uh nowadays there's a lot of companies
talking about being a cdp and
definitely lots of companies have
aspects that um uh have had the elements
of a cdp um
what when i think about a cdp and i i
think a lot about
the cdp infrastructure
like where it's true infrastructure for
the whole company
where the job of the ctp is to get data
from all around the company
uh clean it make it trustworthy and then
get it out to all the corners of the
company to really uh democratize the
data all around
that's what i think about when i think
about the infrastructure style of cdp
currently are also
suites of applications
that have cdps in it
we tend to work with companies that
that
like to have the best of breed
applications so if you think about the
sas services you have around the company
you may have several and with the modern
evolving world and cloud services
innovation happening all the time
many companies really want the very very
best tools and so at some level you need
some level of flexibility and
independence and ease of switching out
these tools for the very very best ones
and when they come along
it's a little bit different than you
are a company whose strategy is to buy a
suite be all in on a suite
if you are a company who is like all in
on a suite um
then
the job of the cbp is not necessarily to
put data all around the company but it's
to get data into that suite um and so
then there might be a different type of
cdp that you have there
and there are other types that you know
they specialize in like one aspect of
activation it may be analytics um and
they would also need to get all the data
in so their cdp may be focused on
getting the data in so they can do the
specific analytics on it or the
orchestration on it
ours is a bit more agnostic ours is
really allowing you to pick the best of
breed for analytics or orchestration or
whatever you want um and then to allow
you the flexibility the power for your
developers to uh to be agile with your
data got it
so so you're drawing a contrast between
the infrastructure cdp and
i'm not sure if did you call it the
application cdp i think maybe you've um
used that term in the past yeah like i
think about infrastructure ctp and app
based cdps right and we're more on the
infrastructure side
got it
um and so
like
let's talk about the the main use cases
of a cdp like sort of the basic use
cases first so that folks can get a
clear idea as to how this deck is used
um and and and what companies typically
use it most for
sure oh well but let's separate what you
use most for versus what often leads
and what often leads
the
the initial need for a cdp uh comes from
marketing that's historically what
starts it uh starts the whole thing
rolling and my experience at amazon that
was also what drove the initial
desire it was centered our internal cdb
was actually centered in the performance
marketing team
and the reason why it's so important for
marketing is because as any marketer
knows the secret of the game is all
around personalizations relevance is
targeting
if you want to do the best targeting
you've got to get access to like the
whole customer you got to understand the
customer and any marketer can look
around the company and say oh you have
that bit of data about the customer i
wish i had that and you have that bit of
data and i wish i had that and if i had
that i could personalize it better and
better for the customer which helps the
customer
lowers our spend and then gives us
better results
so that's often what starts the whole
thing
so you get that driven by the desire to
personalize for marketing now as you go
along you find out oh you know
we really could do that for like on-site
merchandising
we could use that data and
personalization for predictions you
could use it for inventory management
you could use it for um pricing
um if you ever had this experience where
you go to customer service like you go
to amazon and you say oh hey i have this
return to make um and they will say oh
you know
uh you know keep the product and uh
and
we'll give you a refund
you can make that determination because
the price of returning the shipping is
more than the price of the product
and then you could do some things there
on the other hand you could say oh with
personalization you understand that
customer you understand better whether
they are aren't trying to game you
you can understand also if they have a
great experience
their engagement their loyalty might
increase and their spend might increase
and so then the value of having a great
experience might be more than the cost
of that one product so that's all about
personalization how do you actually
understand and customize um for that
specific customer what's the right way
of handling for the customer and that
goes to the contact center as well as
on-site pricing marketing it goes across
an entire company
got it
and i've heard that some companies have
scores sort of internal scores for
customers that they they keep track of i
i guess that's the sort of the most
simplified way of representing sort of a
bunch of different
data points that might inform that
customer service rep um how to handle a
return or how lacks to be on the return
policy
um
i'm presuming that that's stuff that's
all driven by a cdp
um i know the best is to drive that base
cdp but the cdp can unlock more than a
score for a person i think that one of
the things that you wanna that i think
the ideal is
what is the lifetime value of the person
what is the delta of a specific action
like how much will that one action
change the lifetime value of that
customer
and at that time because that same
action a week ago a month ago or a week
or month later will have a different
value so it's not just about the score
for that person but what is this what is
the value for that for the customer
value
what is the delta for an action at this
moment in time like if you find that
trifecta i think that's incredibly
powerful and that's unlocked by a great
utilization of cdp and the analytics
around it
and and from a sort of application stack
standpoint um obviously the the
infrastructure that sort of collects and
connects and captures all this data
is the core cdp value prop that you
mentioned previously what about the
analytics and the models
and the algorithms that run on top of
that um do you typically see that as
part of the cdp
vendors and their stack
or is this some sort of separate
analytics and models that companies have
to implement on top of their cdp
no
the world is evolving and growing and
really rapidly so i think that uh
historically if you go wind back several
years uh infrastructure cdps would not
necessarily have that but as we move
forward i think that there's more and
more of that coming into play all that
said if you talk to a
data scientist
the dirty secret that they'll tell you
if you uh
get under
give to give you the truth is that
ninety percent of the time
they're spending cleaning data they're
collecting and cleaning data and getting
permission to use the data and like ten
percent of time they're actually doing
analytics and so unfortunately that's
the state of the world today and so the
focus i think for
uh for uh where we can provide the
greatest value right now is just
reducing that ninety percent
getting great clean data permission uh
permissions for it and give you the
confidence trustworthiness that you can
then utilize and activate that data
got it
um and and from a sort of an
implementation standpoint um
do you typically see that that cdps
maintain their own set of data separate
from the data warehouse or is this
data that that they typically land in
the warehouse
you know
typically the the cdp does not serve as
like the single source of truth
for the data it moves the data around uh
it cleans the data
it gets it to the destinations so the
cdb works really well in conjunction
with uh a data warehouse um i think that
data warehouse is kind of like is your
warehouse were you like dump everything
in and then when you want to activate it
in a specific place
in a downstream tool a cdp can really
help you take that warehouse of
everything
and then get it to place in the way that
is most useful so i think that as
as uh the modern data stack evolves and
people understand it better the they'll
understand how these really work in
conjunction and support each other
so in some ways when you describe it
like that um it makes me think of the
the so-called sort of newfangled reverse
etl category um how would you say
sort of the the principles of cdps are
different or or similar um to reverse
etl
yeah um you know the the world is
evolving and i think the the innovation
around things like this is just amazing
um
reverse ctl is uh like allows you to
connect uh and go straight from your
data warehouse
to the
to the downstream system
a bunch of the services that we provide
in a cdp is really around uh reconciling
identities reconcile discrepancies
giving you a
central place to manage that enforce
that
cleaning the data so it's not
not what the cdp needs to do is not just
get the data from one place another
but to
get it to a in a form that is usable
trustable uh trust trustworthy um and
then of course like reconciling the
multiple different uh data points into a
single user profile
anyone who works with consumers will
know that you have multiple data points
uh touch points with the consumer where
they can identify themselves
you'll have multiple versions of what
looks like the truth and at some point
you've got to bring that and reconcile
that together
makes sense
um well well moving on to sort of talk
about how this
relates to m and particle um how would
you articulate m particles product
values
yep for first it comes down to three key
things um number one is trust
uh enabling customers to really trust
the data like throughout our discussion
so far you've heard me use that term
many times um and uh
only if you have the data clean and
trustworthy can you really activate it
and if you
don't have it then you run a risk of
breaking your your consumers your
customers trust so it's nothing more
important than trustworthy data
from a infrastructure point of view
we believe in the flexibility
that you give the power to the uh the
developers and to the company to
bend our product to their will the the
flexibility the capabilities of ours are
not just uh focused on one use case but
we want to open up use cases that we've
never thought of so the power the
flexibility the transparency uh to allow
a developer if they wish to to get into
the product
change its behaviors and really bend it
to the will optimize the cdp
that flexibility is incredibly important
and then
of course
empowering our customers at the end of
the day data is like potential energy
and our our value is to make sure that
that potential energy can get unlocked
as quickly as
most
useful and the most useful way for
customers as we can so
making it trustworthy giving a lot of
flexibility and power and then enabling
our customers
and so you mentioned um developers there
a couple times and i think that's
probably um because of the nature of the
the infrastructure-like nature of the
imparticle
product correct um you see your main
users as developers versus
other lines of business um or business
users um actually one of the things i
like about um uh and particle and what
that was really important in my
experience with amazon is that it's
really important that you don't focus on
one
constituent because it data is a team
sport the developer
is often asked to like really activate
the data to really like make it useful
it's a ton of work to keep up with all
the regulations
there's this the cso or the privacy or
data officer who is in charge of making
sure that the company abides by
the regulations and the trust of the
customer and you can't ignore that
person so you've got to do a great job
for
that whoever owns governance and then of
course at the end of the day
there's the marketer or the on-site
personalization
owner or whoever's trying to turn all
that data
into
actions for the consumers and you have
to serve that and so we really uh take a
view of
having the balance where we're serving
uh those three in a balanced sort of way
we definitely believe that data is a
team sport you can't just focus on one
got it
um and how would you say that um
you you position m particle sort of in
the context of the other competitors
in the space
well
as i said i think that uh
we
uh pride ourselves in being cdp
infrastructure um i think if you look
across uh the uh the competitors out
there
most of them focus on a specific use
case or another uh they're more on the
application or suite side um there are a
few who really look at the uh
look at the whole thing as
infrastructure for the whole company um
this is kind of natural and because a
lot of times the use cases are really
driven by the marketer but we take a
long view of it and that we believe that
in the fullness of time the whole
company will really see and get the
benefit of out of the cdp out of
consumer data and
marketers will lead
but they won't be the
the last stop um
investment for serving the entire
company
and so a little bit more generally like
as a product expert and um and a product
builder for years
do you find it helpful to
define um for yourself or for the team
um who's not your customer
um
we
i don't think about it as who's not the
customer i think about which are the use
cases we're not currently
focusing on right i like to really think
about things more in the use case and
i'd love to think about from an
end-to-end use case scenario like
but the customer is visiting the website
um that is generating a set of data that
we want to immediately on the very next
page personalize and understand and
personalize
think through that use case think
through all the people that really need
to play a role from the developer who's
collecting the data uh the the
merchandiser who's making that decision
um and also the data governance who
wants to make sure that everything you
do there is uh is above board and and
compliance um
i like to think about that use case and
then the players that have to support
that use case
we uh i wrote an article um
a couple years ago uh in collaboration
with a couple people in the community
um on
20 20 new data tools and and what they
don't do and we found it illuminating to
sort of force folks to think of
articulating um what they didn't do
which obviously is juxtaposed to to what
they do do
and that was a fun sort of a you know
reverse kind of spin on
um allowing someone to explain the
benefit to their product while also
being clear about you know
areas or use cases or features that
they're that they're not trying to go
into
absolutely and
every company has
more that they want to do than they have
the time resources to do at least at
that time
and i'm a big believer and i think about
the final outcome you want to achieve
attain
and then work backwards from that
outcome and uh and then make sure you
solve that end-to-end
[Music]
yeah wow that that that's a great advice
so in terms of where you sit in the rest
of the modern data stack
um what are the tools does m particle
play nicely with
um you know
we're fortunate to have a ton of great
uh partners um if you were to go to our
website
we have about 300 integration partners
so we uh get data from a
large number of sources and then we push
data out to a large number so uh we will
push data out to
uh advertising tools uh like your uh
google ads and facebook and uh and that
sort of things will push out to
analytics tools um we will ingest uh
data from like uh
all the sources were around that you get
we have uh great kits that
that collect data from
your android and ios apps and your
website um so we have a ton of
integrations that were uh that we're
really proud of um hard to hard to pick
our favorites it's like a chill asking
which is your favorite child
um
but i think one of the things that i'm
really proud of from
a company perspective is just the
breadth right like when we want to serve
our customer
um if we can only
handle like two of their integrations
but they have five or six or ten
then we're not doing a good enough job
for them so the breadth that we have is
really important because as i said
the goal is to get data from all around
the company and push it back out
to all of the company
got it
so tell us about some of your
favorite use cases or features that are
on the roadmap that you're most excited
about coming down the pipe
uh uh
well um
uh
you know i i can't announce all too many
things but you know one of the things
that uh that we've started uh the
rollout for that i'm super super excited
about is uh
this uh new notion of uh we call it
tiered events
if you think about the events all the
customer events that you collect
honestly they're not all created equal
a
a mouse click here um a page view there
a purchase event
like
those are very different and they have
different levels of importance uh to you
they have different levels of impact um
some of them are really critical that
like you will use for a lot of
calculations you will use for
predictions
and some of them are sort of important
in the moment
but you know a month later
two months later you might not care so
much about it you're not going to do
like necessarily personalization on a
mouse click on a specific thing unless
that thing
was a specific interesting value
so we're introducing the notion of
tiered events
some of the events may be uh ephemeral
where you know you you'll pass through
or go to on-screen systems but you don't
really need to store it replay it have
business contributing backups and that
sort of stuff um whereas other ones are
more in the uh place where is import it
is important to have business continuity
it is important to be able to replay um
and then other ones are ones where
you're really going to do a lot of
analytics on uh you're going to have ml
on it you're going to want to visualize
it
and our cured advanced infrastructure uh
gives
our customers a lot of power and
flexibility
to then
pump in a lot of data like very fine
grain that may be ephemeral but super
low cost
other ones that you know you really want
to put more through the paces um and
then those are the ones that will you'll
have more machinery on you'll do more
calculations on so by curing the vents
and having uh them
be pushed to different parts of the
system
you can optimize how we work
optimize our audience calculations
because they can go faster because it
only has to go through and work on the
data set that you know has relevance and
you can ignore all the others
and so that power flexibility gives
improves our latency uh helps you
control costs
and just allow it gives you an idea for
what we think about when we say we want
to give our customers really the power
the flexibility to control and
manipulate the systems got it that
sounds really cool um can you give us a
specific example of how like what a
customer use case would be um in using
tiered events
sure like uh
if if you go to a lot of uh
uh
services in our class you'll hear
um many customers say oh you know
we had to
uh stop setting a certain set of events
to school because we're getting charged
a lot
of those events and so they had to make
these hard triage calls
and implicitly they're then making
sacrifices okay
i think that's okay
to not have those events there um and it
will only minimally hurt our
personalization
we don't want you to make that sort of
choice and so we want to be able to
handle more and more data coming in and
uh and use them appropriately so we
would in the fullness of time i would
love to be able to
uh from a thermal event even track like
every little mouse move every little
instance and layer onto the metadata
behind it that helps you really
understand and put in context love to
track like every event that the customer
actually has so you can do the best by
them so our use case is really not
having you to make hard decisions about
what you do or don't have in your whole
data stack
that's the that fundamentally that's the
purpose
and
so it becomes a cost saving largely it's
a cost saving mechanism
um for customers so that customers don't
have to decide which events to store and
which not to
well there's a cost savings but you
can't forget the latency if you're going
to bring in all the data
but in order to do and personalization
you have to grind through all the data
you're going to slow down your systems
and so it's also a performance uh
response issue as well
yep got it that makes sense
great sheet well um
you know
it's been great chatting with you um i'm
curious
you know a couple questions before we
let you go um what do you think's the
the largest version
of m particle as a company
the largest person uh version of and
particle you know
when
when i think about the future for
uh and particle uh and this the space
oh and i going from my experience uh at
amazon
and looking at
what the potential has
i think that very very few companies
really understand the power of the cdp
um and i
many companies will say they have a cdp
but when i look at it like
it's in this infancy
the ability to
really uh
have every company that works with any
customer
understand the customer better and be
really relevant to them i think it has
so much uh potential for the world if
you think about all the spam that people
get all the uh irrelevant communications
that
should all be solved
and that not only benefits consumers but
it really benefits businesses because
that's a lot of time and money wasted um
the most
every customer wants to enter into a
relationship with the business and feel
like
they're they're the the number one
customer they're really understood
and that's what we can provide for every
single business on the planet uh and
that i think that's the potential that i
want to achieve
yeah yeah that's a high calling and i'm
sure
all of us as um
you know not just founders but as
consumers ourselves um would want that
uh
that that version of the world as well
so that that makes perfect sense
well what's what surprised you most in
your work in the modern data ecosystem
so far achieved
um
you know what's really been impressive
and i love it is uh how much that
the evolution is just accelerating um
the amount of data that we've collected
over the past couple years uh has
outseeded exceeded the amount of data
we've collected in the past three
decades
uh there are lots of uh terrible
downsides of this whole covet pandemic
but one of the upsides is really the
amount of data that
that businesses are able to collect with
people going online so much and to turn
that around
into activating it and having better
services for customers and the
willingness for the world to move there
and that's really surprised me the most
um just the pace of innovation the
acceleration um as it's just not
stopping
yeah it is definitely a very fast moving
space and
um one can only assume that that's
because of the the fact that so many
huge volumes of data um continue to pile
up with no end in sight yeah absolutely
well it's been great to chat with yuchi
and um we're excited to have him
particle at the upcoming data council in
austin
um i know that you and your team um will
be there joining us
uh in in
um in the meantime how can folks get a
hold of you um if they want to learn
more about emparticle or ask you any cdp
questions yeah well um uh love to talk
uh about the space i'm very passionate
about it uh of course you have all the
standard ways easy to find people
nowadays i'm on linkedin and all that
and also my email address at work is uh
very guessable
okay
it's really simple
sounds good well thanks for availing
yourself to the community and um looking
forward to catching up with you on the
progress that i'm particles made in the
future
absolutely thank you for your time
and thanks to all of our listeners um
don't forget that data council is coming
up it's our first
post pandemic in person event
at the end of march march 23rd and 24th
in austin
next up on dc thursday in a couple weeks
we'll have
mohamed elgin d from kolena who will be
talking about ml model testing
uh so don't forget to subscribe to
youtube so that you get notifications
about our next events
and we'll see you all soon